[Музика] Гм, у -е міжнародні друзі, ми
просимо
вас евакуювати та врятувати наших дітей та
жінок, що
є шість днів, що бомбардують, як
ви знаєте, що Гарке ​​сьогодні бомбардував
Центральну площу та всі інші цивільні
райони та жінки  знаходяться на
вулицях їхнє тіло на вулицях
Сівіра Денис лише годину тому
розбомбили
будинок для сиріт
, тому нам потрібна ваша допомога, нам
потрібно врятувати наших дітей і жінок, щоб
евакуюватися, тому нам потрібно, щоб ви
наглядали за
нашими автобусами гм  безпечні території, ми
звертаємося до вас від імені українського
парламенту, депутата Марії Іванової та всіх
інших моїх колег,
діяти якомога швидше,
тому що наші діти та
жінки гинуть і їх
убивають щохвилини щохвилини  годину
дякую
любов гаразд